aunque pocos lo sepan se hacen cálculos
matemáticos para las escenas de agentes
secretos en las películas e incluso se
utilizan los teoremas de pitágoras y de
tales es muy común que los agentes estén
en una azotea y que tengan que llegar al
edificio de enfrente lanzando una cuerda
y deslizándose por ella
siempre pasa algo así en las películas
pero te imaginas qué pasaría si la
cuerda no es lo suficientemente larga
por eso se debe calcular la distancia
entre una azotea y otra pero es bastante
complicado medir a esa altura
y aquí es donde entran en acción las
clases para espías pitagóricos porque
formando un triángulo rectángulo es como
sabremos la distancia entre las azoteas
el triángulo rectángulo se forma de esta
manera con los dos edificios entonces es
tan fácil como calcular la hipotenusa
osea la distancia entre las dos azoteas
para saber cuánta cuerda necesitaremos
entonces es tan fácil cómo calcular la
hipotenusa o sea la distancia entre las
dos azoteas para saber cuánta cuerda
necesitaremos recuerda que la hipotenusa
es el lado opuesto al ángulo recto y
siempre es el lado más largo para saber
las otras dos medidas recurrimos al
teorema de tales tales nos indica que
dos triángulos semejantes tendrán
medidas proporcionales así que ponemos a
nuestro agente a caminar hacia atrás
hasta formar un segundo triángulo esto
se logra cuando la cabeza de la gente va
en línea recta con las dos esquinas de
las azoteas
el agente mide 180 y para llegar a este
punto camino 2.4 metros
así que tenemos las medidas de este
triángulo de aquí
solo nos hace falta una medida del
triángulo original como la diferencia
entre un edificio y otro es de un piso y
cada piso mide tres metros
esta es la altura del triángulo original
quitemos el fondo de los edificios para
ver nuestros triángulos con más claridad
con esta información es muy fácil
calcular la base de nuestro triángulo
grande
si te fijas la altura del triángulo
grande será de 4.8 metros porque tenemos
3 metros y luego 1.8 y la base será
proporcional a 2.4 así que colocamos los
datos que tenemos para obtener una
relación proporcional la relación entre
1.8 y 2.4 será la misma que entre 4.8 y
la base como no sabemos su valor
colocamos una equis multiplicamos 2.4
por 4.8 y es igual a 11.52 esto entre
1.8 nos da como resultado 6
punto 4 eso indica que la base del
triángulo grande mide 6.4 si restamos
los 2.4 metros del triángulo de arriba
tenemos que la base original mide 4
metros
ya tenemos la medida de nuestros dos
catetos es decir de los dos lados que
tocan el ángulo recto aplicando el
teorema de pitágoras tenemos que la suma
del cuadrado de los dos catetos es igual
al cuadrado de la hipotenusa
sustituyendo tenemos cuatro al cuadrado
más tres al cuadrado es igual a c al
cuadrado
si lo desarrollamos sería 16 9 es igual
a 25 al despejar tenemos que la
hipotenusa que se representa con la
letra c es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
25 es decir 5 nuestro agente secreto
necesitará 5 metros de cuerda para
llegar a salvo hasta la otra azotea
aunque yo sigo pensando que es más
seguro cruzar la calle a nivel de piso
puedes poner en acción lo aprendido
poniendo pasos en escenas de este tipo y
calculando las medidas con los teoremas
de tales y pitágoras